The liver is only 10% of the body's mass and consumes one quarter of the oxygen brought in by red blood cells, almost as much as does the brain.
Sugars, amino acids, that's good. Digestion is going very well.
Where are they going, Lieutenant?
To the liver, of course. It's a big sugar store, the liver, and it's a protein factory.
Protein? What's that?
Protein is the main building material for many parts of the body, like bricks for building a house.
Is the body going to build houses?
Oh, don't be such an idiot.
Proteins are used to make red corpuscles, blood plasma, and lots of other things besides.
Even those antibodies are made of protein.
And look, vitamins. The liver will hold them in reserve.
Is there anything the liver can't do, Lieutenant?
Of course. It has its limitations.
And you've got to keep a good lookout because the liver is sensitive.
It picks up infections easily.
You can handle that one for me.
That globulus has just been digested.
I can well believe it. In you go.
Sir?
That's all right. Go straight in.
We're pet tarts, don't you know?
Useful chaps to have around if you're making protein.
What sort of a load have you got in there today, sir?
Well, it's like this, sir.
They're toxins, aren't they?
Thought so.
We don't tolerate toxins.
Please take them for disposal.
Sugars, please come aboard.
You can go to the bile production unit.
It's over there.
You're needed by the protein assembly units.
The ribosomes, over there.
Aha, just what we've been waiting for.
Some sugar.
You can go straight in.
Stocks are getting a bit low.
Suspicious substances are coming through, chief.
What are we going to do?
And millions of amino acids. What's our next step, chief?
Sugar, chief. Tons of it.
Oh, maestro, I'm absolutely overloaded with cholesterol.
And being delivered by what shall we do, chief?
All right, to begin with, we take in the chemicals,
we store them, we convert them,
and we supply them again when they're in the barn.
Now get on with it, gentlemen.
We're not going to panic, are we?
They had a big order for bile, maestro.
They need it for dissolving fat.
That's one of our main jobs, you know, to help with the digestion.
You'd better deliver it right away.
Reading says, sugar urgently, sign to-
Maestro, the brain needs sugar urgently, I'm afraid, sir.
And I'm afraid that it's quite a normal request, because the brain has no reserves of its own.
And it's our job to send sugar upstairs on demand, so get busy.
See, you want an urgent sugar delivery to the brain to be sent via the hepatic vein.
Kiwaki!
We've got an urgent delivery for the brain. Who's available?
I'm ready to normal rates.
You can send it express if you want to.
We're all as ready for urgent deliveries.
Well, I'm cleared for takeoff.
Well, it's for the brain, which automatically gets priority.
Okay, pilot, you've got the job.
You know, Fred, I wish I knew why the brain needs so much sugar.
It works a lot.
Yes, I suppose so.
Just like us.
For the brain.
By the hepatic vein and general circulation.
Let her go!
It's one of our biggest customers and suppliers, too.
I don't give a hoot.
I hate working with carbon dioxide.
It makes me sick.
Soon we'll be in the lungs and you'll get oxygen.
I'm sure that you can manage to hold out until then.
I hope so. It's only the thought of oxygen that keeps me going, you know.
It's exceeding the speed limit, friend.
Listen, you're interfering with the smooth flow of traffic in my vein. That's what's eating me.
Hold your horses.
You're a febrile marshal. I had no idea.
I got a whole herd of sugar to drive up to the brain.
You take priority, sir.
Show me you can do it.
It's easy. I'll even do it twice running. Watch.
It's okay.
What happened?
I lost my grip, that's all.
Any wound, no matter how slight, can be a source of infection, Lieutenant.
We need platelets.
I don't see any.
Where are they, do you think?
They've been alerted. They should be along any minute.
Firm on the foot, huh?
What we need is plenty of fibrin.
You're quite right.
A wound will never heal without fibrin to bind it together.
As you can.
See about the fibrin.
Make him disturb the chief.
Must we?
I wish you blithering idiots would stop your dithering, we need-
Baaaah!
A nasty scrape that won't stop bleeding, where's the-
Now, who woke me up?
This had better be an emergency.
What's this about fibrin?
Oh, Chief, we've got a nasty scrape that's not healing up.
Stop dithering, then.
Get over there and place an order for fibrinogen.
Oh, fibrinogen, Chief.
Not fibrin.
Right away.
We need fibrinogen urgently.
Maestro, why do you order fibrinogen when we're short of fibrin?
I don't understand.
It's very simple, really.
Is that so?
Fibrin resembles a strong web of fibers which holds everything together.
And this web is woven on the spot out of individual strands of fibrinogen.
Now, what could be simpler than that?
Wave those wagons through before the other traffic.
Because they carry emergency supplies of fibrinogen to repair the blood vessel.
Whoa!
Dear old chief, the arms are tired. There's not a moment to lose.
We need more sugar for energy and protein for the muscles.
Don't hang about, then. It's our job to produce sugar and protein.
May I show you something fascinating?
Things that go on here.
more salt get straight in that's more salt that's good more water takes a lot of water does bile
that the sample chief confirms to all the standards specified by the body it's very high
quality bile this that's very gratifying you can send it off right away oh here i am chief don't
worry i've got it hold the stuff yes it is wait till you take it out of my sight highly ordered
sir we're ready to start production at short notice sir this is an important matter the whole
Bile plant is standing by.
Just what do you two think you're playing at?
You've gone and smashed an item of laboratory equipment.
You're going to have to wake your ideas up in future, young man.
Now, let's put all that behind us.
What was in it, by the way?
Sir, it was the bile sample for your approval, actually.
In that case, you can start production without delay.
Yes, sir.
Let's go, Chief.
Get on with it.
This always makes me feel so bilious.
Take care of it, Chief.
Why don't you have a little nap?
I'm doing myself a favor.
When the boss gets bilious, he vents his spleen on me.
It's ready to pour!
Even eat it without the bread.
What are they?
Cholesterol.
That's what they are.
Oh, what's it for, sir?
Oh, we use it to make a multitude of things.
Biles, cell walls, even hormones.
We only use a little, but we'd be lost without it.
Wanted salt molecules this way!
Cell on cholesterol units.
You're needed for building up the nuclear membrane.
Just step this way, won't you?
So you've brought me some cholesterol.
And it's nice and fresh, straight from the liver.
Go below!
Hey, what do you think you're doing?
You'll cause a blockage if you're not careful.
Your attention, please.
There is a blockage developing in coronary artery number four.
It is restricted.
Liver will cease cholesterol production immediately.
I repeat, liver will cease...
This is ridiculous.
All that cholesterol wasn't manufactured in the liver.
Wash your hands, Jumbo.
Bet you forgot, you always do.
We'll multiply.
Hmm?
Let me start now, Foxy.
I'm glad you asked me that question,
'cause it reveals your profound ignorance.
We are hepatitis viruses, you numbskull.
You're going to stage a coup in the liver and take up all the chemical works.
Now follow me.
I'll give you a lift. Hop in.
Along the hepatic portal vessel.
Not anything to declare.
There are a load of amino acids. They've just been digested.
Have a look at them.
Okay, take them to a ribosome.
And look lively.
Inside the cell are the ribosomes.
Little assembly lines for the manufacture of protein.
The ribosomes duplicate them strictly according to the coded instructions
on the long RNA molecule sent out by the nucleus.
You see, a strip of RNA has been sent out by the nucleus of the cell
and they're making an exact copy, a protein.
So we grab the protein and run, do we?
Dimwit, proteins don't interest me in the slightest.
All right, now what does interest you?
Do you see that? It's a ribosome.
Hmm?
A ribosome is a factory.
But we're not interested in what it makes.
Until we issue it with a new set of instructions.
Our very own DNA molecule.
They will use this to reprogram the factory and you'll be really amazed at what it starts turning out.
They know what they're doing upstairs. I just follow orders, that's all.
The situation is serious.
The liver has been invaded by type A hepatitis virus.
Calling security force. The situation is deteriorating.
All units respond immediately.
I feel sick.
I don't know what's the matter. Maybe I ate too much.
Maybe, but sounds to me like jaundice.
Infected cells have notified their neighbors who've already begun to produce interferon to defend themselves against the virus.
That's great! We could do with some help from interferon.
As interferon heroes, we have need of your superpowers.
This cell is threatened by the forces of evil, a horde of Hepatitis A.
Now is the time for us to strike. Order the ships to divide before we counter-attack.
All lymphocyte ships commence multiplication exercise.
For days. Don't you get bored with it. It's a shame.
Yes, Peter, jaundice makes you feel awful, but not quite as awful as the special diets they put